so your family is like rich we're
comfortable that is exactly what a super
rich person would say the romantic
comedy crazy rich Asians opens today
amid lots of buzz about its potential to
shatter stereotypes it's predicted to
have a big impact at the box office this
weekend with estimates that it could
break in more than 25 million dollars
there's a lot more riding on it than
just ticket sales for the all Asian cast
CBS Sunday mornings Lee Cowan spoke with
a movie's director about how he hopes
the film can make a cultural impact in
Hollywood these people aren't just rich
okay
they're crazy rich in a better world we
wouldn't be talking about the ethnicity
of the caste and crazy rich Asians I'm
talking about whether or not they give a
good performance most critics agree they
do we've been dating for over a year now
and I think it's about time people met
my beautiful girlfriend but it's the
oddity of an all-asian cast that's still
drawing headlines and for director Jon M
Chu that's just fine oh no I hope that
in 10 years we look back at this moment
and we forget about it we're like this
was that was a thing and all Asian cast
was a thing it is a thing given that
this is the first studio film since The
Joy Luck Club way back in 1993 to
feature an asian-american on some when
Chu a veteran of Hollywood set out to
bring Kevin Kwan's popular novel to life
he knew it would be a watershed moment
but he had no idea just how much it
would affect him personally is the most
present movie I've ever made which means
were going through this cultural
identity crisis at the same time of
making it I cry every for hours thinking
about it because you feel that your
movie is more than just for yourself at
that point Chu an Asian American whose
parents owned a Chinese restaurant loved
movies as a kid that's him dressed as
Yoda but he rarely saw anyone who looked
or sounded like him on the big screen
she realized as a director he wasn't
casting Asians either
and whose part of the problem I think
for myself as an artist I wanted to know
that I was an artist like what do I have
the courage to push something through
this system that I now have known so
well for the last ten years
so that desire grew too much for me to
hold inside and and it was it was it was
time Rebekah son is a senior reporter at
The Hollywood Reporter movies are her
life and yet this one felt decidedly
different to see one about a
chinese-american girl like myself who
looks and dresses like me was it was
incredible it felt really really
validating in a felt like recognition
the stakes for tonight's opening are
high and so are the expectations maybe
impossibly do you think it's a black
panther kind of moment in film
I mean it's tricky because it's hard to
compare anything to my pair there it's a
it's a it's a you know amazing piece of
work that has changed the landscape we
are on the beginning of a journey and I
think this cracks the door you'd be
happy if it just does that I'd be happy
if people go to the movie and it'd have
a great time you can't take back what
you see I think I'm just wanting love
with you wherever I can and what you see
is a romantic comedy about a boy and a
girl and the complexity of family that
could be almost anyone almost anyway and
that's the point
for CBS this morning we Cal Poly at the
end of the day we all want to see a
really good movie but I can see why this
could be a sense of pride for the Asian
American community them much the way
black Americans felt about Wakanda
forever but at the end of the day you
still want a good movie and he ignored
you a part of the problem yeah I can't
wait to see this movie me too
let's go together yeah